all right miyoki
miyoki uh where did you grow up where
are you from originally
i was born in springfield illinois
um i'm an army brat so i've kind of been
like everywhere
um
but mostly springfield illinois that's
my roots which is close to st louis yes
it's a hour away from st louis yeah and
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were young
yes i did actually um
i had three parents
four um my mom and my dad split
when i was really young so
i had my stepdad and that's who was in
the army and then i had my stepmom and i
alternated
um parents like for
sports and
stuff like that it was it was cool for
me good childhood
yeah
no no traumatic events no abuse nothing
like that i mean
no child can say they had a perfect life
of course i had um traumatic experiences
but
um they don't trump the good experience
i had at all that's correct
what kind of kid were you in high school
i'm sorry what kind of kid were you in
high school
i was to be honest
i was a follower i was a follower um i
didn't really know myself i loved myself
i was a middle child so
you don't really get
all the attention as a middle child
so i was just a follower and
um i was in sports so i did track and
cheerleading and just was always trying
to be in the in crowd and
do what everybody else was doing
pretty much
you went to you graduated high school no
i did not no um
[Music]
life changed in high school for me so um
just with my parents and
um
certain arrangements we had so
i ended up just kind of dropping out and
doing my own thing being really
rebellious i think that's when my
rebellious stages started about 17 18. i
actually dropped out my 11th grade here
and when did uh stripping kind of come
into your life
it came into my life two and a half
years ago
um
i had something that was coming up that
i really needed the money for and um i
sold rvs and cars and i was a server and
the money just
i wasn't able it wasn't coming in fast
enough for me to save it the bills were
adding up and
right i think it just wasn't it wasn't
coming out the way i wanted it to
so so you started doing
the dancing and the dancing supplemented
your income it did actually i was able
to save up in two months i was able to
save up almost five thousand dollars
um and
my daughter came for
her spring break and we did everything
that she planned
so she had a little plan that she wanted
us to do a list of things she wanted to
do we were able to do that and more
so i just kind of stuck to it like i
never i never stopped like how could i
how could i stop you you've been doing
it how long now um it'll be three years
it's going on three years
so
and and so you've talked about some of
the upsides of doing this kind of work
what are the downsides
everything has an upside and downside of
course um the downside
i guess if you want to
keep a certain
name and you want to keep a certain
appearance you
you pass up a lot of
fun opportunities you know um
a lot of things that would be fun but it
just doesn't look good it's not a good
look and it doesn't
it kind of
keeps the
stereotype of strippers up and so i
choose not to do it
so i don't really have a personal life
an intimate life at all
i missed a lot of birthday parties a lot
of family functions family vacations
because it was a big party coming up and
i wanted to make the money and the
weekends are the way the time to do that
and yeah and there's no like i work
every weekend like i don't go on dates i
you know i just
i stay in the house and watch true crime
one day until it's time to go to work
and then i'm at work and i don't live in
tampa so i only get to like be in my
home
for like
two days a day
if it's a busy week so you'll drive to
tampa and you'll and i'll stay here with
my best friend
um i have a room at her house
and we'll be there i'll be in
i'll be at her house like
all week
basically
do you enjoy this work or
um do you just do it because it's good
money
i did enjoy it at first
i've
met a lot of people in the industry
um what is the industry the music
industry i've danced for
rod wave i've danced for cash dawg
to see
i've danced for a lot of people that um
that do music that's something really
fun for me i love music
um
but it's still not like you know it's
something that you know it's it's my
stepping stone right now but it's
something i'm definitely ready and
looking forward to be done with
does it affect you emotionally
of course it does
of course it is um
well
i started natural my body was natural
and
you know
men
they want their wife natural they want
their girlfriend natural their stripper
they want her plastic
so i had a lot of um
just a lot of problems just being really
insecure with my body in the way i and
i got surgery i got boobs and i got lipo
and now i want butt and you just you're
never satisfied and you're never happy
with yourself and this life can really
suck you in and
you know you
i have to drink to work so i'm a totally
different person when i'm drunk so
you know hearing like you know how i may
have made somebody feel or
something like that like you know it's
just it gets it gets to be too much and
it makes you feel really
hollow like you're a shell
body image must be a huge thing in this
industry yes because you're never going
to be good enough there's always some
girl who's
body's better whatever yeah her hair is
better
and she made more money last night than
you did or whatever
yes and that's always a thing like you
know you have to as a dancer what the
best thing to learn is to never pay
attention to
money that people are making like if i
see a girl over there making five
thousand dollars and i've only made five
dollars yeah it's
it's it's disappointing for the moment
but i you know i have to congratulate
her in my head keep positive and be like
you know i'm gonna go make eight
thousand dollars i'm gonna make ten
thousand dollars and you know whether
it's unreal realistic or not it helps me
and um it helps me empower other women
that's working because i'm big with
women empowerment and
i just keep pushing i think it's
important for women and men i guess to
understand that
what you have to offer
is a dream come true for the right guy
right he's not going to be the the
perfect body or a perfect beautiful
woman for every guy but you're going to
be the woman for a certain for somebody
and that that was that girl's night yeah
so you were just witnessing that but
that doesn't mean that you're not fanta
just as fantastic exactly
you have to understand there's
difference
everywhere everybody likes something
different and i always some guys like
him skinny some guys like him with them
with a big butt yeah some i i have met
guys who's like i love the fact that
you're natural
and you know and they throw money on me
just because of that um yeah i think a
lot of women lose track of that
and it's easy to look at the world yeah
who still has their natural body body
other than alicia keys
nobody
um and this is one thing about me though
that i've learned i'm gonna make me some
money
like i'm gonna go in there i'm gonna
dance um i'm not big on talking but i'll
talk and i'm gonna make me some money
and there and even if a guy don't like
the way i look the way i dance it's
something about me that's gonna persuade
some money up out of somebody and i'm
gonna make me some money it's just
i don't know if it's just it's art
dancing stripping however you want to
say it it's the art it really is yeah
are you lonely
extremely
extremely i'm 28 so
and you're beautiful and you'd think
that there'd be
a guy in your life that makes you happy
no
it's not
and
i'm not i'm definitely not gonna find
him in the strip club
um do you think there's no chance of
that no chance i wouldn't even entertain
it i don't date people
that i meet in the club nor do i date
people that live in tampa
so i have strict rules
no i think those are probably good rules
not the tampa part but the strip club
part yeah and it just it just keeps like
it keeps my face clean i don't you know
it's not a good look to be in the club
and like three guys have had sex with
you in that club like you know i like to
be the girl in the club that nobody
slept with and i mean tampa's big but
temp is small especially in the dance
like tampa is stripper stripper world
like
i'm learning the temp is nudist colony
like there's more nudist colonies in
this tampa area than anywhere on a
planet and then same thing with strip
clubs there's there's how many strip
clubs in this city i think there's like
over
500 who needs that many strip clubs
tampa in vegas man like that's that this
is this i think it's got vegas beat i
believe you i definitely believe you and
i
i mean it's just it's so small so
you know i don't date people that work
in the club i don't do people that go to
the club
so lonely
yes
very lonely but i
am not going to say i'm unhappy but i'm
content with the way life is going for
me right now because i know this is just
a stepping stone and
it's just it's not going to be perfect
you seem to have a good head on your
shoulders and you seem to understand
where you're at what you're doing and
the the limitations of that
which is which is
helpful
it comes i think it comes with the age
yeah i think um if i would have started
dancing when i was 21 or 22
i would want to be a
super stripper star
like we have some
girls here that are they travel the
world everybody knows them shout out to
red carpet
um shout out to milana those two girls
are really big dancers they're really
sweet girls and it's a career for them
they have they have merchandise and
they're just they're well-known names
tell me about the what goes on at strip
clubs what what what goes on strip clubs
that girlfriends and wives don't know
about
secrets um
well
i've never witnessed it i've only heard
stories and it's a new wave of dancers
like the 2020 well 2019 the
2021 right now it's like a new wave of
dancers so i don't think it's going on
as much
but you know
there's
you know there's some things that goes
on in the back rooms
and
um you know
link sneaky links after the club and
stuff like that ways for the ladies to
make some additional money yes exactly
but
that's never a good idea
because if you make more money on your
fact than you make on your beak you are
always cheating yourself when you do
that
i've made on my birthday
i made sixteen thousand dollars
why would i lay on my back
for less than sixteen thousand dollars
when i made sixteen thousand dollars in
less than an hour on my feet drunk
having fun just laughing and dancing on
the stage
why have sex with somebody late like
give give my soul and my body away for
less than what i made on my feet and
it's supposed to be priceless anyway
it makes no sense
and it just
it really brings us down but what
emotions does doing this this kind of
work
bring on
i'm irritable i'm more irritable i'm a
little more
my i already had a temper but my temper
is way shorter now do you feel like
you're just in general
because you're doing this kind of work
you're disrespected
oh constantly every day
every day i deal with disrespect
every night and
i could be the type of female in 20
different forms every night right right
because so it's not just that you're
telling about your body for money but
there's also just the way guys will
dismiss just look at you yeah dismiss me
um we you know we get disrespected by
our promoters we get disrespected by our
dj's
um just and we it's just you know we are
the reason why they come to the club
they don't come to the club to see our
promoters in a thong i assure you
so
we should really get more respect but
life doesn't work like that and that's
why and i'm and i'm glad that it's not
that easy and it's not that sweet and
because
hopefully that gives people
girls
a plan a reason to have a plan and want
to get out of it because this is nothing
that you spend more than five six years
in
not to me
my my limit is three years so yeah i
think i think a woman pays a price
for doing this for a long time that you
just
you'll spend the same amount of time
digging your life back
rebuilding it
in a healthy way that you did
well i mean all the damage you've done
yeah that's if you don't play it smart
if you don't play as smart and you
because the only thing that
i
will have when i get older um
and i would just have to explain it my
other i have an eight-year-old daughter
her name is lola gray she's the most
beautiful girl in the world
and
you know i will have to explain to her
you know i mommy did this
so we could do this you know
that's the point of having a plan and
using all this money that i've saved and
accumulated to
start my business and to just
you know create a foundation because i
didn't graduate from high school
you know and there's there was nobody
that was
that had a plan for me i had to plan for
myself so
do you think life just the world life is
just too difficult and too too
competitive and too
doggy dog you just there is no way for a
person in general or someone like
yourself maybe without a full high
school education to
to support
her family or her self and her kid or
whatever no i don't feel like that and i
don't feel like that's a good excuse
i did this because it was quick
and i it i
i made a lot of bad decisions
as a kid like in the in my rebellious
stages not going to college not
graduating high school
not caring about my future
i'm not tapping into my talents because
in this day and age people are getting
rich for saying
just saying things and they're going
viral and they're getting rich and
people are making
businesses online and online boutiques
this is a route because it's quick it's
easy there's no work
it's a scapegoat
do you think it was a mistake when you
do it no i don't regret it at all and
i'm not gonna i'm not i'm not gonna quit
until
i've reached my you know i've reached
the limit you know and
no it's not a mistake i don't regret it
i don't wish i never would have did it
i you know it's just
it's what i've went with are you
addicted to it
yes very much the fast money very much
so every night that i don't work
i'm on instagram looking at our
promoters and i'm like how much money do
how much money are they doing what are
they doing yeah am i mad i miss that
money like it consumes me
it consumes me
definitely so
you know i i definitely i definitely
feel like
i'm gonna miss it when it's over i'm
gonna miss it i'm definitely gonna miss
it you'll miss the money yeah i miss the
money and i and these girls
you know i can't speak for all the girls
but i've came across some really good
girls like you know don't get me wrong
these girls are
they're
everything negative that people say but
they are still a person
and if you catch them outside the club
you can sometimes see the person that
they really are because
we we are two people i'm miyoki and i'm
myself the name that my mother gave me
and
everybody else is just like that too
yeah things get very competitive
amongst amongst the girls in the club
right very very much so
very much
very catty yes very catty very physical
very verbal how are the promoters the
people you're working for at the clubs
they're new age pimps
and i'm not ashamed or or scared to say
it
they charge us ridiculous prices for
house you actually pay to dance right we
paid to dance
they charge us ridiculous people pay you
you pay them exactly
they um you know they just
i
don't i they are
good guys at heart i'm sure
but when it comes to us they don't have
our best they don't have our best
interest it's not about us it's about
how much money we can bring them
and
you know i don't really have too much
good to say about
promoters
i love my promoters don't get me wrong
i love them because i work with them but
they can be very slimy
when you were a young girl do you have
dreams of doing something different with
your life yes i did what do i do
um
my favorite movie was the devil wears
prada
and i wanted to work in journalism
i wanted to be where all the action
was and i love literature
so maybe be a blogger
on the red carpet interviewing people i
love to be in front of the camera i love
to talk
maybe have a talk show
i didn't i didn't have like just one
thing because i love sex in the city too
and so i wanted to do i wanted to write
be a writer which i still can so it's
not things that i cannot
obtain now no you can still do it yeah
you can you can wait 25 years and do it
still do it and still do it look at
wendy williams she's about to crook over
she still hasn't
yeah i don't think there's ever a time
limit on anything
and your daughter's doing well yes she
is she's very happy she's very happy
um
she
she
thinks that i'm a bartender
so
um it's not anything that i keep from
her
just because she's not ready yeah i'm
very honest with my child so one day
sure enough a lot of girls that do this
kind of work working strip clubs will
travel around the country do you you
don't travel because your daughter i do
i travel i go to atlanta well i have
anxiety so
sometimes when i travel
it makes me nervous to go to a new club
but i've been to atlanta
um i've been to st louis
so i plan to travel more
so you'll drink every night when you yes
i'm drunk
there's no way to not do it no
drunk right
no i have to i mean but my drunk
is like normal right
like i'd be
like i wouldn't normally be like this
drunk but just probably like a little
more
it loosens you up makes you feel sorry
yeah
definitely i have no filter i say
whatever i want
well the strip club that works but it
works well it works
they love that
and what's the most important lesson
you've learned
the most the most important lesson i've
learned
is
just keep holding yourself
keep hold of yourself your integrity
your self-love your morals your
standards just keep hold of it and keep
hold of it tight
and remind yourself of who you are
not the dancer you but who you are like
who you really are because
it's easy to forget
it's easy to forget
[Music]
all right okay thank you so much for
sharing your story
i hope you make a lot of money tonight
thank you thank you thank you thank you
very much you're welcome
you